what's up everybody I'm Walter Brennan
and this is top five here we countdown
the best and worst performances of our
most beloved actors today we take a look
at the best of the 26 year old
phenomenon Jennifer Lawrence wait
26 I'm older than her oh man this top
five is the result of a Twitter poll I
put up asking who should be the first
actress covered on top five more polls
will be going up on there soon so if you
want your voice heard make sure to
follow me on twitter at awesome
underscore Walter Jennifer Lawrence has
accomplished a lot for her age she's
already an Oscar winner and has been
nominated three other times while she
doesn't yet have as much work as other
subjects I've covered on this show most
of the stuff that she's done has either
been critically acclaimed a box-office
success or both I'm sure it'll just get
better from here but at this point in
her young career these are her top five
best performances number five Tiffany
Maxwell in silver linings playbook
Jennifer Lawrence can be really good at
playing erratic unpredictable characters
this is the role that won her her
Academy Award for Best Supporting
Actress and it's not difficult to see
why based on the 2008 Matthew quick
novel after spending time in a mental
institution former teacher Pat solatano
moves back in with his parents his
obsession with getting back together
with his ex-wife consumes him and to
make things more complicated his
friend's sister-in-law Tiffany promises
the help Pat if he agrees to join her as
a dance partner in an upcoming
competition a thing I've noticed with
Lawrence for a while now is that she
plays characters that seem significantly
older than her most of the time she
pulls it off while Tiffany's age isn't
mentioned in the film that I recall she
acts like a woman more in her 30s than
somebody in her early 20s it's
convincing in this role as she also
layers being a widow with her own set of
mental issues to match Pat's on top of
it she can be very funny in this movie
with some good comedic timing and when
she snaps her heads to get emotional she
shines pretty well you're a hip
your conformist you're a liar I opened
up to you and you judged me you're an
asshole
it's well-established that Bradley
Cooper and Jennifer Lawrence have some
solid chemistry and the duo along with
Robert De Niro and director David
O'Russell have teamed together on
several more projects also shout-out to
Chris Tucker for gracing the silver
screen again we miss you Chris number
for Agnes in the poker house this is a
little-known movie that Lawrence did
back in 2008 she was in her late teens
and it showcases just how talented she
was even at that age the movie itself
isn't very good but Lawrence turns in a
very strong performance Agnes is the
oldest of three sisters who constantly
struggle from day to day in a home that
has been taken over by pimps and
gamblers while her mother has succumbed
to prostitution after the violent
divorce from her abusive husband this is
based on the childhood of actress Lori
petty you may remember her from a league
of their own Tank Girl Free Willy and
orange is the new black this was her
directorial debut and it's obviously an
extremely personal film lawrence plays
the dramatized version of petty as a
teenager and she is very believable in
this role it's different seeing her so
young she's very charismatic and likable
here especially when she's interacting
with her sisters
I'm sorry I love you bye she gets to
show off her range in a few dramatic
scenes that cap off a great turn from
the up-and-comer at this point
and he sells oh me too
and you wouldn't die yes the movies
problems stem from a wildly inconsistent
tone that goes from very cutesy too
shocking without much of a warning the
poker house gets very uncomfortable and
it's not for everyone
however Lawrence really showed off what
a talent she was as her star was on the
rise number three
joy Mangano in joy this just came out
last year and was the latest team-up
Lawrence did with director David
O'Russell it didn't get a lot of
commercial attention but Lawrence was
once again nominated for an Oscar for
her performance as a real-life
entrepreneur joy Mangano's joy is
constantly taken advantage of by her
family she's a pushover who gave up on
her dreams many years ago
however joins grandmother still believes
in her and encourages her as she creates
the world's first self-renewing mop as
the product becomes popular joy has to
deal with an unforgiving business world
while balancing it with her family
problems this role stands out from the
pack for Lawrence as we see her react to
new situations with a very different
demeanor she's a mom who lets her family
walk all over her the sympathy factor
plays a big role in having us root for
joy throughout the movie
it's an understated performance that
blooms into something special as the
film progresses you are really on our
side is this underdog scores victories
and racks up losses while selling your
product another big element that leads
to some great scenes is the relationship
that joy has with her father and
half-sister maybe my product is better
than your product never speak on my
behalf
about my business again we see joy
chains as she rides a rollercoaster ride
that dips her into some low lows and
eventually transforms her for the better
not the best David O'Russell movie but I
think it's a really nice story that a
lot of people can connect with Lawrence
as Joy's a joy sorry
number two Katniss Everdeen in The
Hunger Games Catching Fire based on the
second Suzanne Collins novel in The
Hunger Games series Catching Fire
explores the ramifications of the
unprecedented wind that Katniss Everdeen
and Peeta Mellark pulled off in the
first movie now they are forced on a
Victor's tour ending with an
announcement about the 75th annual
Hunger Games and third Quarter Quell
that changes things in an unexpected and
cruel way instantly we see that Katniss
is a deeper character than in the first
film and she goes through even more in
Catching Fire it's her best performance
as Katniss in the best Hunger Games
Movies correlation ships are explored in
more meaningful ways and Lawrence really
ups the ante in those emotional scenes
as well as in the action sequences in
the Quarter Quell
when those actions seem to intersect
with the emotional ones we see some
great stuff from Lawrence I think the
most interesting aspect to Katniss this
time around is how she deals with people
starting to look at her as a leader and
symbol of resistance to President Snow
and the Capitals she sees all this
happening but can't go too far with a
knowledge in it since snow has
threatened her family and I couldn't
save her I'm sorry
[Music]
her badass side is of course always
present I think my favorite example of
this is when she sends a message to the
new game maker Plutarch
when Katniss is brought out of the games
and sees hemic Plutarch and Haymitch in
the ship
her reaction is a release of frustration
that holds a ton of weight and Lawrence
portrays this rage perfectly they got
him and Joana the ending is a great
tease and got just about everyone really
excited for the finale which would be
split into two movies this is what
Lawrence is best known for and she
doesn't disappoint as Katniss
specifically in this movie Jennifer
Lawrence hasn't been around for all that
long but she still has more than just
five very good performances so before we
get to number one let's take a look at
some honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Jennifer
Lawrence performance is read Ollie in
Winter's Bone this was the performance
that really made a lot of people take
notice of the young actress it was her
first Oscar nomination and in my opinion
this is positively her best performance
seventeen-year-old read Ollie is the de
facto head of her household after her
father goes missing having to take care
of her two younger siblings and
unresponsive mother things only get
worse when she's informed by the sheriff
that Rhys father put the family's house
up for bond she is then forced to go on
a dangerous journey to find out what
happened to her father all with the fate
of her family hanging in the balance
this is based on the 2006 novel by
Daniel Woodrow we've seen Lawrence and
similar types of roles both before and
after this movie but she 100% carries
this film and she hits a bull's-eye with
every scene she's in she's believable
bold and a bit stoic but in a good way
this character presents herself as if
she has no fear but we see as the movie
goes along that she's even more
admirable because of how she overcomes
her fear to take care of her family now
you know I got the legal right to go in
there hunting the man any place out
won't I know you'd be wasting your time
and pissing me off
kill me I guess
I love her relationship with her uncle
teardrop played by John Hawkes there's a
lot of history with Rees dad and their
scenes together are great you should
have this Oh why'd you keep it here for
me
also her relationship with her siblings
is even more enjoyable than in the poker
house she really is the surrogate mom
for these kids and Lawrence plays that
role well now the most important thing
is do not put your finger on the trigger
unless you're ready to shoot you're
aimed at your target and don't ever both
of you look at me
never point this at each other not ever
all right if you're not a fan of her and
haven't seen Winter's Bone
I'd suggest changing that it might just
alter your opinion I want to hear what
you guys think what is your favorite
Jennifer Lawrence movie and/or
performance what do you want me to cover
next in the show leave a comment and let
me know follow me on Twitter at awesome
underscore Walter to take part in more
polls about who may be covered in the
future come back next week when we take
a look at the top 5 worst Jennifer
Lawrence performances farewell
[Music]
[Applause]
you